oh oh we're on okay all right we have so
much content to get through today
because there's so many hidden gems that
we really just want to get into this
there is a lot of people in here if you
are uncomfortable we have been told to
tell you to go to the overflow room it
might be more comfortable for you but I
love seeing everyone crowding the
staircases that's fantastic if there is
a fire I'm sorry you're all gonna die
but it will be worth it because you will
learn about some stuff that we don't
know all right
live David I'm David we have me Damien
uh that's gonna get right in it so
you've probably heard about all this
stuff right all the stuff in and done
they call three blazer G IBC WinForms
and WPF HTTP to new JSON API so did some
stuff we're not gonna talk about any of
that today you've seen all that stuff
you can go read the blog post about that
we're gonna talk about all the commits
and all the PRS and the issues that you
probably haven't seen unless you're
following github like a hawk so let's
start right down the bottom at core CLR
so we have new support in the garbage
collector for defining limits about how
much memory your application will use we
also have new defaults to those limits
so that you'll use less by default so
you can set limits for how much memory
the GC has available to it you can set
it to a percentage of the amount of
physical memory on the machine or you
can say I just want you to be able to
use 500 megabytes okay you can set that
fire environment variables right now and
there is a runtime api you can use to
get information about those limits why
is that interesting you might have code
that wants to know how much memory is
available before it does something okay
the new defaults use much less than
before so if I switch over to this graph
this is a graph of one of the HP net
core the plaintext benchmark and you can
see that in some time in April we went
from using your oscillating between 300
to 500 megabytes of process work a set
address space memory straight down to
our just under 100 okay and that was a
combination of a few things
but one of them was these new defaults
in 2.2 this test used to use 1.3
gigabytes of address space memory now it
uses a hundred and that is partly thanks
to these new limits here in these new
defaults all right moving on assembly
load context
this is a new API was available in
previous versions of.net core but it's
much more powerful now you can use this
to build a plug-in model who's ever used
app domains before to build plug-in
models and applications okay that's
fantastic AB domains don't work and
don't that call they're not there so
this is the replacement for app domains
it determines the assembly paths for a
given application path and assembly name
for you using this assembly dependency
resolver and allows you to tap into the
built in logic in the host that knows
how to locate an assembly located to
relative assemblies based on where the
application was booted from etc etc
people heard of fusion the old assembly
loading stuff in net that's gone ok
there's a much simpler assembly loading
algorithm now this thing taps into that
simpler simpler yeah you can unload
these context to free up memory after
you've stopped using the assembly which
is fantastic that was the big thing
people wanted you can resolve both
managed and native assemblies which was
one of the really hard things now that
were cross-platform it's very common to
bring in different native assemblies for
each platform that you're going to with
your library or your application you
need to support that it is not an
isolation boundary the process is still
considered the security isolation
boundary or a VM if you really want to
go hardcore this is not an isolation
boundary for security purposes it does
isolate the assembly identity and the
type identity and it does isolate things
like static values but that's it ok so
don't think of it as a security thing
and it is the success throughout domains
you have a demo for them so just a
warrant these demos are pretty lame
no no they they're focused they're
focused demos for a short timeframe we
have for attention is so much content
all right so have an app here that's
going to show you how to use the
offender context so the app itself
purposes just net which is 12 point all
point to and the application has a main
it's very simple console application I'm
gonna create a custom block context and
you do it by creating a class that
derives from assembly context it
overrides the method call load and this
gets called every time and I say man
look is requested by default if you
don't implement load it'll go to the to
the default context and use the button
logic so there's no change by default
yeah ok so if I run this application it
will create a little context my little
context load didn't learn that into that
context and then it'll get a type from
that context
AJ object we call it G object to object
to object ok
make it happen make it a thing I create
a job jig and then cast it to the job
date somebody fought there's too little
context well but if I there's one
there's the default context so this type
that I'm using in the main is in the
default context this type this instance
is coming from a different look context
right so by default this should just
work if I care because you didn't know
every ride in your logic and it over I'd
load so it should be all the same icon
same types no isolation wrong method
project hit f5 run run low assembly it's
loaded my special get type create object
cast super lame perfect
no okay make this work I'm gonna load
this assembly in a different look
context same assembly same path
different context so think about as a
different instance of that assembly so
the first thing I'll do is create an
assembly dependency resolver resolver
okay Lu it up with the path the base
path will get application itself and I
will inherit a path equals resolver dot
resolve assembly path this will give me
the path for the assembly wherever the
host Dominic it could be in the packet
is folder could be an folder could be
anywhere the host without a body fault
if path Mike was to know I can return
load assembly from path passing in the
path this will load that assembly into
this little context right so now we've
created that isolation I've loaded in
the way the same dll but in the context
so now I'm gonna pass in the path to
this to this application here so type of
program but assembly that location and
now if I run this I see what happens
hit a 5 and I have a new love context I
call load still Sam deal all good
create the job jecht boom era it's
because I know have to look context same
type same assembly like name but
different instance like I cloned it and
created these era is bizarre I can't
cast job to job checked right but
they're different low context ok so this
shows how you have a different boundary
of isolation if you want like plugins to
be loaded separately ok I'm the one last
thing I want to show you is that there's
a an oval in here I can do compassed
base and say unload is flexible if you
unreferenced the load card inside of it
it'll get GC by the copper smelter cool
alright alright sweet
alright startup hooks so this gives you
the ability to register code that will
run before the applications program main
alright so you think about ways that
might be useful for you you said it you
do it by setting an environment variable
when the application is booting or just
before the application is booting with
the path to an assembly ok and an
assembly name for the runtime to go and
find path or a named path or name sorry
path or name and it'll go and find that
it'll then look inside that assembly for
a type with a specific shape right it's
all pattern matching kind of magic and
then it will call that method and run
that before program main ok now there's
a whole bunch of things you can start
your demo there's a bunch of things that
might want to use this so if you're
using application insights or service
fabric uses this in Asia so that they
can inject code into your application
once your application is running in
their context so you don't have to take
a dependency on their SDK and add a
package you just run your app in service
fabric and then they can inject extra
magic into you when you're running there
ok all right so here is a basic console
application I've found your project
Pritz hello world in long sitting
thought Jason I have this environment
variables I got die set called dotnet
startup hooks with a full path to a hook
see my hook DLL ok my hook is right here
in the same project it has to not have a
namespace it has to be in troops
internal
before internal class startup hug is
that the hard-coded name that's
hard-coded in the runtime and public
static void initialize why is it not
interface or type or anything just as a
to not have dependencies in the runtime
and look I'd be fair now graph yourself
I mean see goosey could be in there but
okay good reasons I bet if I run this
application it should print out this
this before the hello world okay okay
okay so we got your poker okay perfect
they worked oh just sure I mean debugger
it's kind of but it worked so I'm sure
there's like three people audience going
I'm gonna use this that's fantastic all
right diagnostics improvements Donna
chorus now cross-platform as you all
well know as a result we don't have the
benefit along the deep history of
Windows diagnostics and performance
analysis tools that a lot of us have
been relying on for doctor apps for for
20 years and so we've had to do a whole
bunch of investment to in to bring up a
stack of new diagnostic tools and
diagnostic hooks so that you can do this
stuff cross-platform so we have a new
set of global net tools is releasing
along with got neck or three neck
counters neck trace and net dump and you
can probably imagine from their names
what those three tools do we also have a
default Diagnostics pipe that is open
for every dotnet core 3 application by
default so you just start you don't make
it call three up everyone that you were
just running has a hidden pipe that is
open that you can attach to to get
Diagnostics information that pipe is a
'cold with the same process identity so
you can't just attach to it if you're
not also running as the user that the
the app itself is running yes okay so it
is secure by default you have runtime
api's for accessing runtime counters for
GC and thread pool and those type of
things there's also a new SOS command
called dump async which is useful for
diagnosing a sink or hangs
hangs or blocked all hand tasks and
those type of things with like just a
nice dump of information that's relevant
to that there's also now the ability to
force the process to cry out to dump
when there is a crash so if you have an
unhandled exception in your application
and unwinds or a background exception or
something like that you can set this
complex variable before application
start and then the host will for
a dump of that if the application
crashes so we have a demo of a bunch of
these new tools all right stuff all
right all right so I will use this
application it's a website we're going
from console to web this found you I
think API has a weather controller this
is brand-new you saw it here first so
before yeah oh this is the new one in
the tempest in preview seven this will
be the new values control super useful
yeah returns weather in Celsius and
Fahrenheit all right so I'm gonna I'm
gonna start this process Oh something
else that's fine basic application very
lame bad demo but I can run a tool that
I happen to have in one of these
applications one of these windows that's
awesome and James is talking to you
dinette by counters to get perform who's
ever used performance countries on
Windows perf Candice right perfmon this
is the replacement for that I'm the
cross placement for that tour right so I
can run the dinette counters list
processes to see what things are running
Oh God which one is it
back-end dotnet how would I know said
eyes Express or I could is run itself
that makes it easier easier perfect and
that's not working right now call back
later for a 5/5 that's an interesting
error
so I clock still ticking it's okay so
you got time right sure like an hour fix
it go five wait hold on that's the wrong
app too many apps running oh I gotta
have a really go there I'd value some
stuff so dance dance
really something make you demo work um
kill okay all right so movie set me do
this from one machine because it would
be better now I'm regretting that this
is Gary all right so this should run and
I should have one thing running that
works with the one process running let's
Isis price so I went done it counters
monitor - P this thing 8 3 6 8 system
runtime and Microsoft Hispanic or
hosting cool
so here the counters on my screen for a
spot net core and for the runtime under
CPUs is working said things are all
useful you can read the screen so I'm
gonna hit this with a bunch of load no
hopefully this end point in some useful
when do I have a tool called Bombardier
so to create load on the site like a be
or work mm-hmm
hit Oh didn't come probably hit this
endpoint here I mean duration like 1c
seconds all right
alright so the numbers are moving
there's the RPS there's a current
request allocation or eight bytes per
second super useful great for if you've
ever monitored performance counters to
look at this type information this works
cross-platform you can do this today you
can try this on the latest preview bits
you can install these tools as a dotnet
global tool from Newgate and you can see
this stuff all right another tool the
next lesson now if your purse sucks
your purse sucks you can run net on the
same process run net trace trace collect
I know we use all of your hardware space
I heard hard drives but makes me super
league chancy get it done that's an M as
long as it's an M you're fine when it
changes to a little upset alright the
changes to a tee just give up close
it'll walk offstage pedabytes alright so
now I should be how big is your
supercomputer straight to the cloud
yes all right Chris is then I have a
trace and my user Bo gosh
there it is Troy still net / I don't
want to put it there there's a file a
new file format called net perf I think
it's gonna rename that is that it is
right now in that perf right now it's
net / and you can open it in now that is
the new name it was net collect or
something wasn't it crazy it was that
trying it now it's net race it's gonna
be natural it tricks right it's now that
it's gonna get okay
right nice and that fer aiming is hard
please do so you could use then why her
use per few couples okay
the profiler in Visual Studio anyone use
the CPU profiler in Visual Studio okay
yeah few people yeah all right so tell
trace JetBrains doc trace it now that
porous this new format let's open this
file format you have to do it in a fresh
instance done you can see that okay and
it will load the CPU tools and I can see
what is low in my app whoo now that
could I have collected that on a Linux
machine as you can then brought this
over to vs that's right
lovelies that's something that's really
hard to do today yeah so now you can
just take that trace formula or inside a
container or whatever it might be and
then just bring it over
yes and you can use the existing tools
awesome anything else um one more thing
it doesn't super work oh then maybe
that's not worth showing the tool okay
there's one more tool that totally works
sometimes
is this the dotnet dumped all right yep
okay so I have like so on Windows
creating a process dump is fairly
straightforward you go to task manager
your right mouse click and say create
dump or you go to your proc dumped our
xe4 exists internals and you run that
you have a dump on linux it's not so
straightforward there there are some
tools the don't that core team had
shipped previously in the runtime create
dump it was inside the runtime but now
we have a one tool to rule them all
no matter where you are what don't mess
up that works really well
that will create a dump for you okay no
matter where you are with the heap
information so that you can do the
memory analysis for the snapshot
afterwards and you also do dotnet if
this worked it does sometimes didn't
before
I came here so right so I've collected a
time analyze the dump file called dump
that one day and it gives you a command
line up to analyze your application that
can run help to see what commands there
is just like SOS this is like this is
basically SOS built-in without having a
debugger so you choose SOS and windbg
for dotnet right so now you've just got
it here and again could I have taken
that dump on Linux and then brought this
over to Windows and run this command no
no okay that's unfortunate
it's close you're working on it see if
this works it dumped you okay yeah I got
this this morning but never mind the
Reds work oh right and not the name but
this soup out with the double with wsl
too right
I'm Windows yeah with the kernel with
the UNIX and the thing yeah I could run
this into a WS l2 and with Linux and and
hope you'll work and hope it'll work
yeah we're working on all this we're
trying to make it as easy as possible
for you to use this stuff across
platform it is turns out it's quite
complicated all right we're good oh yeah
all right publish options so there's
three new publish options in net core
three that enable you to optimize your
published application in different ways
some of these currently have kind of
laser focused on the wind forms and WPF
desktop app scenarios but they're not
limited to those you can use them for
application types console apps and even
web applications if you think through it
a little bit so one of them is ready to
run most of you I'm assuming I've heard
of engine with net which lets you pre
JIT accept that runs on the target
machine you don't really run engine as
the developer you run it after it's been
installed on the machine that makes it a
little inflexible so we have this thing
called ready to run which pre jits your
application during publish it'll
generate ready to run images for your
application along with the managed
images and all get shipped together it
is a form of ahead of time compiling or
pre jet which I said someone to engine
you do get slightly larger files because
it does mean that you take over a little
bit of native code as well as the
original IL code with your application
lately slightly hosts lately quite a lot
slightly yes yeah just like I am
slightly smarter than you maybe slightly
better looking I don't know we'll just
keep doing this
and then after the application has
started up the new tier compilation
system which was optional to point to
but is now on by default in three Oh
will identify hot paths of your
application and then reach it those with
ever more enhanced or better JIT
algorithms which maybe a little slower
but will produce faster code okay and
that's really important because the
ready to run images themselves are
actually slower at runtime they're
faster to start because you don't need
to get them but they can't generate as
efficient code because they don't know
what CPU you had ahead of time and they
can't optimize things like inline code
across assembly boundaries and all these
types of advanced things when it comes
to ginning so the combination of ready
to run images and tier compilation in
theory gives you the best of both worlds
okay can you be a little to other
platforms from so from Windows can I
publish for Linux so you'll note that
there in the command line you have to
pass the target platform when you do
ready to run okay so cuz you have to
know where you're going to generate
native code the question is can I do
that for another platform and I think
the answer is it depends
just say yes yes yeah okay do we have
you made that work for everything like
can you do arm from x86 I think I'm yeah
BX 64 at least anyway so maybe is the
answer publish options single file who
love people have indicated that maybe
when they publish their application they
get a little sad when they see hundreds
and hundreds of files in the output
especially if they're doing a
self-contained application that takes
the whole dotnet call runtime and shoves
it in their application just zip it you
could just zip it and then you have to
do it yourself out here then you have to
deploy then you have to unzip it okay
but this is effectively what this does
for you so you can say now /p or put
this in your project file publish single
file true again it needs a read so it
can generate you the native executable
that will launch your app but then you
have one file it's pretty big
because it's a big file that contains
your entire application if you put it
works for both framework dependent
dotnet core apps and self-contained
net core apps and then you have a single
file you can take that over you can run
it
it'll self extract itself to a temp
location the first time you run it and
then it will run from there then the
next time you run it it'll detect that's
already extracted itself and then will
run from that location okay
it's pretty cool and then lastly we have
assembly linking which is a little like
in the old days we had now it's not like
that it's not like I'll merge its you
know it's from mono and it's a set of
technologies that will look at all the
code try to statically analyze parts of
your application or code base that
aren't used okay after it's compiled and
then tree shake those out okay you can
configure it because sometimes they
can't figure that out and it will shake
things out that it shouldn't have shaken
because you're doing like light up or
reflection all those type of things and
so you can tell it hey I know I really
do need that assembly or that type
please don't get rid of that and
again you can just pass this through
publish give it a read and you're off to
the races and you can use all three of
these things together to give yourself
you know ready to run preach it plus
assembly link trimmed out plus a single
file don't work not in preview six but a
will in preview seven and you have a
demo of using one or two of these at
least I try it okay
let's combine Ashley verbatim okay so I
have an application in wall these
windows somewhere this one nope alright
so same app I just ran the ice
application I will maybe stop it first
aggressively stop it by killing it to
him just got violent dot name done it
publish /p what a single file it's true
publish single file to publish single
file true are when x86 1666 alright
publish to see what happens
crunching everything together into one
file just like crunching it all crunched
down wrench she's done
it's crunched it's super that look at
that lovely it's kind of one file if you
if you don't look at the other two files
I mean obviously the PDB is separate
there we go it never was never there
this file is Matt I mean I mean is that
too big 77 Meg that's huge big but you
know with the previous I'm gonna keep
working on it yeah and also my config
file is gone yeah where'd it go well you
just deleted two files that you know so
there were three files well configure
one was DB yeah where is the so by
default right now this was a web app but
is the way back right now as I said this
is kind of this has been targeted at the
desktop applications
it works perfectly for that for web
applications a spinet cause default
locations that looks and stuff has not
been updated to allow it to find things
from the temporary location from a place
that's different to where it launched
from we do intend to do that at some
point but what we're gonna do in the
meantime is update the West web SDK to
not bundle static files right so the web
SDK today yeah so it explodes horribly
the web SDK today will by default look
for JSON files and images and CSS and
JavaScript etc etc during publish and
copy those with your application you
don't to say all that you see as project
just doesn't automatically and then the
bundling tool here just goes oh great
I'll suck all that up and stick it
inside myself and then I'll extract it
out to the temple ocation than we boot
from here yeah I know and then we'll say
yeah it was hungry and then it will it
winner boots from here we go looking for
those files in this folder and we don't
find it was slow actually yeah the first
look yeah because I had to unzip I had
to unarchive so many searches franca
bytes over to think all right hey what
you want to feel quickly so you can work
around this right now if you put a
little bit of msbuild goop in your
project file just to tell it to not
bundle the static assets that you need
to make the application run from that
location you can do that there's an
issue logged it has this details in it
but we will make this work as I said
more targeted at console apps and
desktop packed apps right now for now
all right anything else on that yeah one
more thing ah publish and I need like
one window this is that one this one
this is good one all right publish was
last one publish trimmed trimmed publish
trimmed this is the assembly linking
alright this is the same app trimming
trimming superher same at yep okay get
rid of assembly he's doing out of ass
analysis erasing functional features I
don't it's going old con Mari on your
application so here's the bin folder by
default and here is the size without
size without well oh with oh it's being
trimmed set
six Meg's okay 76 Meg's on disk but
after a bit of exercise and diet
I see less files - Wow okay 46 max
that's not too bad
does it still work not sure okay but if
we erased the folder and move on to the
next slide doesn't matter okay fair
enough so it does work fairly well for
you know out of the box works fairly
well for simple applications but as I
said once you start doing things a
little more advanced which I see a core
does by default that's early reflection
reflection yeah but you know not
everyone does but it might do it
underneath you without you knowing like
a snake for you yes yeah for you then
you may need to instruct the linker
about some things all right
so native interrupts improvements for
those folks who are doing native
interrupts which is uh you know
sometimes common in Windows desktop
applications which is one of the reasons
we're bringing into dock nickel 3 we now
have support for manage C++ CLI
commenter up is now supported in dotnet
core obviously these two when you work
on windows and we know it's on window
and WinRT only work on windows but you
now have first-class support for doing
all of those from windows.net core 3
applications there's a new type called
native library which is kind of the
imperative equivalent of dll import and
so rather than decorating a method stub
with dll import you can now imperative
Li load native assemblies and use the
CLR logic to go and find where they
should you know log load from and do all
the goodness there are you have some
samples for calm all right so I'm 64
support so this is a brand-new
architecture than we support now in
dotnet caught three or four Linux only
right now to start out with so if you're
running Linux IOT for example on top of
an arm 64 board or you have an advanced
scenario we've got a Linux server so x
64 that's a thing I've heard maybe then
you we do support that and also we have
hardware intrinsic support now so that
you can from managed code detect if your
CPU supports like avx-512 we've got some
super expensive Xeon processor and then
utilize those AP is from managed code to
do you know vectorization and all that
kind of wonderful stuff advanced stuff
the inbox UT
fate encoding which is obviously very
relevant in web applications and a spear
core uses by default has been fully
optimized using all of these new
hardware intrinsic supports all right
let's move out of the CLR and up into
the bc l api's for everybody all right i
a sync disposable so you you have a
disposable object now you can implement
icing disposable which will allow the
runtime to disposed that using an async
code path this is particularly useful
for cases where you have like a stream
or anything doing io where if it gets
disposed while it still has a buffer
internally and during dispose it will
implicitly flush the buffer to whoever
was listening on the other side today
that can cause real problems because
that now blocks the thread because it
was a synchronous code path disposed
today is a synchronous call if you then
have to do an async flush you have to
wrap that with a synchronous call and
you end up doing this which is super bad
so this this looks safe you do a using
you do await stream rewriting this is
buffered and the suppose will then call
flush synchronously yeah which is bad
which is super bad so instead you could
conflict a sent yourself or in c-sharp
it you can do await using this right
right and then if disposed does get cold
and it does have a buffer that it has to
flush it at least can flush
asynchronously now not block the thread
right while it's happening so that's all
goodness alright distributed tracing for
those who have more complicated service
scenarios where they've got one app that
then talks to another app that then
talks to another app micro services
fighting back and all that type of thing
we now have apt dates to the existing
activity type in which it was introduced
to what three years ago might one don't
like or 2.1 and in dotnet framework or
support for dotnet framework to support
the new w3c trace context standard it is
on by default in a spinet core 3
applications so that if an incoming
request comes in with the right header
format and name we will turn this on and
then flow that information out through
HTTP client if you make an outbound call
again now you can have correlated logs
for that logical transaction that runs
through one app and then jumps over a
process and goes off to another app and
it integrates with open telemetry which
was previously called open sensors to
you that Zipkin style sort of
distributed tracing do you have a demo
of that that's worth showing maybe maybe
if it works we'll let them judge whether
it was worth showing I guess afterwards
know that one red card will be the one
but someone says that wasn't questioning
Oh so let's take the app from or a
workshop that we did okay last week
there's a front-end and the backend
application the front-end is richer
pages black hand is an API controller so
very simple controller in the backend
does business stuff right EF with NBC so
not a big deal when I run the
application so you can see what it does
it's a conference planner I had these
talks from the conference right now I do
want to point out scroll down scroll
down there is someone here who's name is
literally lemon with the Unicode
character for lemon I thought that was
fantastic
we found it yeah and apparently make you
stop hating CSS apparently I want to go
to that talk so the front end calls the
backend API a very simple right this is
the micro service not design so micro
service my 20 years ago we just called
it like in TIA it's the same stuff it is
per app okay fair not enter so you type
in donate course it's two point one that
people may not know about heart activity
anyone know that type is activity buddy
no.11 hand-to-hands those people that
work at the company that does great all
right so activity is basically uh the
current think of it as an ID for the
current contextual ephemeral state this
ephemeral ID that flows boundaries if
you want to have a friend call the back
end you want a flow an ID from the front
end to the back end and add as you go
from services service you want to track
all the calls from in and out times
right so by default on that core 2.1 we
added this type but it's really hard to
use so the goal was in 302 have it all
by default right and have things plug
into it so like so so it would light up
in different situations
so if I look at activity the type of
cell this is to show what it does I have
a current for the current current has a
bunch of properties
Engineering is the ID the ID is the
current spanha t their spans and there's
traces and you can create child spans
like art relativity so imagine request
comes in you make a database call or
several phone calls those are all
individual spans and there's a kind of a
parent hierarchy going on you kind of
imagine the waterfall view and the
chrome dev TS exec hold that this called
that and this call is that this enables
that but server-side bracele it's
notorious one on the incoming request
and should be client will create one
request and correlate them yeah right so
so by default if I put a breakpoint in
the backend code yes because we have one
here for sessions I should see an
incoming request header from the
front-end by default without haven't
done anything okay app runs
it's a back-end if I look at the autos
obscurely dive into the debugger window
into request into headers into something
here header trace parent this is the
actual header but flew from they should
be clients a to be client on the request
from a student from the front
application out of the header called
trace parent which is the w3c trace
context started standard header that
flows to the backend the back hand will
get it and create a another activity for
its request and then other requests will
have other other activity okay what you
can do with this is plug into something
like open senses are not called open
telemetry to get a waterfall view so in
my startup in the backend I have this
awful cool that will get cleaned up at
some point I'm using this thing called
Zipkin is anyone knows if can is dipkin
yeah yeah distributed trace view made by
Twitter it's a tool that just shows a
waterfall model so I have one in the
front end and one in the back end
hopefully this works and I I was told
that I have to make the call take longer
to make it to make it show you something
useful so let me add some latency that's
a lot perf bug okay just in case
forget measure you're creating
opportunities for future improve all
right so this should be running wait
let's hope man I'm imagine that when you
plant isn't this work you put one sleep
in there so you can look like a hero
except you put it in a region so it was
collapsed and that won't pass Cordy
beautiful um so to make this work I have
to do something
that's a docker some stuff Oh someone
who runs it can zip in there's a Java oh
it's already allocated okay let me stop
this thing you've already got oh it
looks dead stop this container from
running and there's zip gained there's
Jaeger and there's a ton of other tools
dynaTrace and op insight so all kind of
tools to do the actual viewing of the
tracing right to ingest this and then
make something useful of it yes so opens
lavatory basically takes our event turns
them into generic spans that are passed
to Zipkin or different exporters mm-hmm
to run the antenna scenario so if I run
this no I should have a view of sorts
okay just to make sure its moist I have
some logs show up I do okay I do need to
run the application at some point
how is Zipkin reading from like where
the logs going if you look at this
configuration the configuration it is
akin says used at endpoint oh just saw
where it says you said this like this
middleware in the two apps that's
available so each app is posting I say
that is it got it got it
VL with census okay so that they were in
the right
did you run it no this one it's running
application again any weird thing is
that the the actual traces to the pin
show up as well oh that's a bug so okay
so it's running it ran if I look at the
pin I should see something there you go
it's fine one span to store water fully
thing we can see I couldn't get it
working alright but in theory this works
really well okay showing the actual
trace it still this will work and to end
its didn't give other Tom Bishop and
this will not show up because this is
gonna work okay
oh it's tracing it starting itself Tracy
okay cool nice so we're making progress
there yeah kind of work sell it man sell
it right run time feature detection so
if you have a library or you're doing
any type of code that wants to emit code
at runtime this is quite popular for
serializers or dependency injection
containers or even our REMS and any
other audio mapper things like that they
have to generate code at runtime and
then compile it to make it faster you
need to be aware of what features the
runtime has available to it you might be
running on iOS because you've got a
xamarin app and then you know there's no
JIT available to you okay but you might
have an interpreter you're running and a
native in a uwp application again no
chip you have an interpreter available
to you for expression compilation and so
we have these two flags that you can use
to detect the conditions of the runtime
and then you can make a decision as the
code author about what it is you want to
do do I support dynamic code being
compiled and is dynamic code even
supported at all okay thread pool
enhancements ok these are another one of
those things that has helped us improve
the performance of a snit core in
version 3 one of them is unsafe q user
work item which does some advanced stuff
with a thing called execution context
which great that's fantastic I throw
people work item is much more
interesting now when you in queue work
into the thread pool you can implement
your own type that the thread pool will
then dispatch to ok so rather than the
thread pool behind the scenes creating
things every time you say run this
please run this run this place which has
a memory overhead you can implement your
own type and you can have a single one
of those that caches things and clears
things in between runs which is what we
do in Estoril that's what we do in the
is module so that when we're doing
millions of requests per second and
we're dispatching all of those i/o
callbacks through the dead thread pool
we're not getting any overhead by doing
so when it comes to memory because we
get to manage all of that inside our own
type
alright so miscellaneous stuff and the
BCL support for processed kill and
support and including the entire process
tree which wasn't there before so you
can pass that now and kill all the child
processes of a process bit operations
type for doing advanced bit twiddling
for people who are really into like math
and image manipulation and stuff like
that sounds waves of sound files I guess
I don't know myself Visual Basic is back
so if you're trying to port an
application for
like a wind forms or WPF application
that was written in VB to donate call 3
this is kind of important because of all
the VB specific namespaces and
functionality might not my dog for
example yet back in deco 3 and then a
small one DB command now supports async
transactions so if you're doing begin
and end transaction when that
transaction ends you can now or even
begins you can call that asynchronously
because there is i/o involved you are
waiting on a database there's now an
async version of that available for you
alright
I've been to the server stuff a spinet
core UNIX domain sockets is now natively
supported and kestrel without having to
use libuv so we used to be based on
libuv the native library that gave us
cross-platform
io it was the same library that node was
based on in a spirit core - we did the
work or two point one point one two by
one we did the work to replant on top of
the system net dot sockets
implementation by default the bv is
still available as a package you can use
it if you want to but by default since
then we use the native sockets in in.net
that now supports UNIX domain sockets
whether you're on Windows 10 or above or
Linux which is fantastic it's really
good for scenarios where you have a
front-end like a reverse proxy that then
needs to talk to your deck or process
and rather than using HTTP to proxy
there you can use UNIX domain sockets
which is just lower overhead okay so
that's on and available to you by
default now static web assets in class
library some good stuff here so if
you've got a razor class library because
you've got razor views or pages or
blazer components that you want to ship
as reusable components inside a library
what do you do with the static assets
with the CSS files and the images in the
JavaScript that supports that well we
now have out-of-the-box default support
for embedding those inside of your
project just as part of the build system
you have to do anything special if the
files are in the project we will find
them and we will compile them in then
when you reference those from your
application we know whether it's a
project a project reference or a project
a new get reference and we will optimize
depending on what that is and we will
set up your a spirit core application to
find those static resources the way you
reference them is with this little
convention so in my application now I
would say the source is underscore
content slash razor Lib one slash hello
DJ s if my name
raise a lid one and then everything just
works by default okay it's really really
nice support for doing so okay is server
variable is another very small one if
you're running a spinet core inside is
up until now you did not have support to
read the server variables which gives
you all that really valuable information
about how the server is configured what
your connection currently is underneath
you to the client and a whole bunch of
information about the request that's now
available to you inside your new core
application system that ioad up pipeline
so as a refresher this is the API that
was effectively extracted from kestrels
guts after a spirit called 2.1 that took
all the great work we did in kestrel for
networking primitives memory management
basically an inversion of the socket
philosophy and net and we now have that
available as a separate set of api's you
can now get access to the raw pipeline
that's underneath your request in
response and read and write from that
pipe okay and then we've read written or
you know some of the things in a spinet
called shuffled them around to use the
pipes directly rather than going through
the stream adapter right usually you
would read the body and you get a stream
type and then you call stream api's you
can now call the pipe api's to do that
instead form parsing is no allegation
for you and form pausing is now allocate
well that's pretty cool
and that is the big advantage of pipes
is because they manage the memory for
you effectively if the pipe person is
doing that you get to reuse kestrels
buffers kestrel was already allocating
memory to deal with the connection to
deal with incoming requests and it's
managing that memory for you you just
want to read from that and have it take
care of it and so form parsing is a
fantastic one because forms can be big
alright
speaking of pipelines and networking
some of the other parts of kestrel which
was how we internally factored the fact
that we have a transport layer and then
a bunch of logic that no matter what the
transport has to deal with memory and
connections and the logic around that
we've pulled out under I think or
project bedrock just a project name is
on the API name but this gives you the
ability to reuse all this logic in your
own libraries whether they be servers or
clients so for example the popular Redis
client that the stack exchange folks
build is using these is going to end up
using these libraries as well the dotnet
signal our client in core uses these
same libraries and so now we have this
really a line
client/server networking abstraction
that doesn't care what actual networking
layer you're using doesn't matter if
it's TCP or HTTP or whatever it might be
it just deals with bytes basically right
at all it is but it gives you all that
logic and we have a WebSocket connection
it's how signal I uses it so I see what
I can show here um all right so this
change actually happens super late
because the Orleans team they actually
copied signalers entirely transport
options into into Orleans we got a
meeting about should we make a public
API to be to set them together designed
an API and it happened to be to be put
in Castro like last month oh wow okay
this is super fresh fresh okay um so
I'll do it inside of application that
has web just because it's simpler
there's no a new interface available
I'll write a new thing this is all
unscripted unscripted scripted okay
let's call it server server one I think
it's going to trust me it's good trust
you with some things I hosted service
this will inject will start it when the
whole starts I'm gonna inject a new
interface called a connection listener
the names okay give us some feedback
truly Java connection listen a factory
factory factory is one know just one I
guess that's a private area listener
factory I know there's a snippet that
automates everything you're typing right
now does it yes just consumed at first
and then control dot little create flow
this feels wrong boom done alright so
async adding value it's amazing factory
dot buying this thing passing in an
endpoint so IP new IP endpoint and this
can be anything any kind of endpoint it
can be a domain stock it could be a file
handle UDP my yet okay you said any oh
Allah be a poor it those no Wars they
won't confirm anything else I'll get my
calendar you know I should
ground service probably better
background listener was introduced in
what version 2.2 point two one
chief on one or two point two two point
one okay background service sorry under
hidden I don't think we talked about it
much
I didn't let's put it in you just
checked image until anyone didn't yeah
all right nice segue background service
is a type you can use in your a snake or
apps to run stuff in the background okay
that's what it is pretty cool to our
servers right and it will coordinate
itself with the lifetime of the
application give you a chance to shut
down etc etc I have a listener I can
accept a sink
get up get a connection and then I keep
thinking that's like a magician doing
sleight of hand so you do know don't
look over there over here so the goal
here it's a hat is to have the a snicker
equivalent of the lower tension ler
alright so you get back a an abstraction
that gives you a listener to something
could be TCP could be named pipes could
be whatever you want reaper in memory
and then you get a connection object
which is your HCB contest equivalent for
a connection and this guy's kind of an
abstraction over it's looking for you
what did you hit power
I was born for f12 aggressively I
thought we can blame Steve Jobs for
originally putting a power bomb in the
top row of a condition that looks like
every other key so here's the context is
this is your HTTP context for
connections it has a bunch of basic
things like ID connection closed
endpoints for your address and transfer
which is your actual okay socket so to
be clear again
this thing doesn't know how the bytes
are getting to me right I know it's a
connection of some sort something but it
doesn't matter I'm just dealing with the
fact that there are things coming in I
want to send stuff out right but the
transport layer that was configured
separately right TCP whatever it might
whatever was fair enough so for example
I know for a fact this app is running
cash flow so it should have the suckage
transport configured right so I'm I'm
passing it an IP IP they know that can
support I said yeah okay so I get a
listener back on this port get a
connection and
and typical while-loop you do when you
write a server if you done before
connections result there's so many times
no connection dot transport you read
from the incoming transport read async
okay get a thing back
if result is completed this is the
pipelines to model if you haven't seen
it before you don't pass in the buffer
one is given to you because it handles
that management for you in the divers
manages the memory for you under the
covers connection transport input
there's a lot of thoughts
buffered and neither is I'm watching
it's okay I need to move this all the
way so now I'm gonna write to the output
connection transport output dot right
just an echo so yep okay just to don't
judge me this is a demo okay don't you
allocate right they won't do to array
just easier for no so this does a loop
until the catch is over and it takes the
incoming bytes that got back writes to
the output and this advance is the
buffer okay anything break right very
simple um this is the whole server so
that's an echo server yeah is anything
it receives it'll send it back
yep okay awesome that's it are you gonna
say I'm gonna connect to it I happen to
have putty in my tree oh just happened
to be there that looks like it tried to
bind to something you already died its
name horribly ok this happened before uh
who is both my port who is taking oh you
know what we have eggsy's no that's what
that's the problem
ok before it was easy no I got search
for a real name hmm
what's the app called oh not that one
but you know what publishing sample I
know things I wrote it was I know the
things work so I can just change great
Oh perfect beautiful wait I should hit
the buck see if it works hold on
actually put a breakpoint here because I
actually get up so I have to actually
add this initially okay you haven't
actually told anyone about it yes what
is it going I hosted service everyone so
no this should get called so I have a
background service in an asp net
application that itself is grabbing the
connection factory from kestrel from the
manor from the container and then saying
create me a new endpoint on a different
port alright that is going to speak is
going to be an echo server yeah okay
along with the HTTP so using TCP because
I know kestrels that is the server in
this case it doesn't know one raw okay
whoo
there you go nice I think they get the
point okay that's good
nice then was super cool now if you've
ever done that with the existing API
isn't net it's not that easy no
especially not to do it a synchronously
and with good memory management all the
rest of it this one is still tied to TCP
but you could abstract this slightly and
have a more generic if you something
else you would be fine and you could get
rid of that buffer allocation if you
wanted that to array if you want to
suite bedrock all right so we got a new
support in routing we've had this
request for ever to support route
matching based on the host right the
request came in to this server because
my server is bound to multiple host
names can I please do routing based on
that and forever we said no and now
we're saying okay and that's in three oh
because we have a new system endpoint
routing and it made it even as he's like
a good time to do it and it was easy to
do so for example you could have a
controller that only matches when the
incoming request came in on a specific
host name okay which is kind of cool
very useful for multi-tenancy scenarios
where you want to have different host
names configured for multiple tenants
and then you want to be able to have
different application parts or types
that only resolve to that or if you want
to expose multiple endpoints like for
example internal only ports and you've
got special logic that you can only get
to if you're on localhost or something
like that so you have a demo of this one
that's worth showing so it's pretty
pretty great okay if you do say so
yourself
okay I made it so it's good okay all
right so here's the demo very fast demo
two actions on the same controller okay
Sam wrote different hosts okay so this
good this one should respond to only a
CPS 5001 this one should respond to HTTP
5,000 okay different name because you
can show me my t-shirt I should run this
no and 5,000 is not you know what you
know what I think it is conference
planner No
it's not it's not alright again six
alright there's a lot of those numbers
so we can do this all day
oh we're nice method ha could I read the
conflict from Kestrel and make that
dynamic I couldn't because it's this one
is a declarative you could add that
route constraint I made a demo
imperative Lee right don't ruin it
okay sorry you can you could though it's
accountable it's possible okay cuz I saw
repeated strings and that just triggers
me why did that everyone drinks because
right doesn't know one there it is 6,000
HTTP doesn't work
unsafe poor unsafe port that's an
awesome error this is okay hold on hold
on you have 12 seconds hold on hold on
what I'm sayin see I've never seen that
before you want David as your device
manager ass that one
oh no wait hold on six one two this is
just horrific on stage okay in front of
you all so this time is gonna work
I plan it's all planned okay port safe
port was six thousand like reserved or
something and then it's ephemeral but
okay there you go
well done nice safe landing alright
support for trailing headers so you can
actually send headers after you've sent
the HTTP response body who knew how long
has that been a thing ever forever
forever there's nothing supported it
yeah okay so we now support that it was
required to support G IPC and we've got
supporting both HTTP client for this and
in
the server and it's useful for doing
things in server programming like
sending perhaps timing information about
how long it took you to process the
request you can't do that until you've
processed the request so you need to
assent the body first and then you could
quickly append a header at the end that
says this is how much time I took we
have made it improvement to the
developer exception page you we can now
send non HTML responses to clients that
don't support HTML so if you ever use
like postman to hit your app during
development and you get an arrow and it
just sends you back a huge blob of HTML
in the thing designed to look at plain
text and Jason now it won't now it will
send you nice plain text exception
details based on the developer
environment which is fantastic
there's also an extensive ility hook eye
developer page exception filter and so
now you can plug in your own custom view
so for example if you wanted to send a
JSON exception format you could for a
specific exception you could we're gonna
update the entity framework cause
specific developer exception page to not
be its own middleware but instead just
plug into this one developer exception
page just to clean things up a bit so
that's coming as well we're not going to
demo this but we've got improvements for
compression up until now we would not
serve anything compressed when you are
over HTTP due to historical security
concerns with attacks like crime and
breach but now we've got support for you
during the request to say no I know this
is safe there's no user data in here
that can be manipulated by the client so
you can't do timing attacks in that type
of thing and then we implement that by
default by the static file middle way so
now static files will get compressed in
a spinet core and they also support
broadly by default now in a submit call
super super helpful we did with them
before that as well but you can do so
you can put code in your razor page or
in a filter arm and I come up with a
scheme for saying I know that this page
is safe it's not ever showing user input
that can be manipulated and so please
compress it all right the last layer
we're gonna have two bursts through this
we've got a system D integration now if
you're hosting a background service like
a Windows service or Linux
that's coming in three oh it just got
checked in like a week ago the ability
to get all of your configuration values
in one big dump which is very useful for
debugging you can do that now with you
get debug view you can validate your
service provider that is the container
when it is being built during
applications start so then instead of
finding out you miss configured
di like 14 requests into the server
starting when you first get a type you
can just have it fail immediately and
that's enabled by default during
development so you can find out very
quickly
we now have support for options
validation so if you're using
configuration and binding those two
options types and you want to make sure
you have a Mista configuration value
there is built-in support now for
writing a method to validate your
options or even using the data
annotations that you use on your models
in MVC and in any framework to validate
your options as well and again the app
will just stop and then you'll know that
you've misconfigured your environment if
you want to use loggers outside of a
spinet core in a console app where
there's no di we've got a factory method
that static that you can do that with
right now and then you can also load
configuration sources like JSON and XML
and any and yam all from streams now so
that you can get them from memory right
from a bit of resources or key vault or
anything like that not just files which
is kind of cool
that is it stuck the landing please
follow us on Twitter ask us any
questions we will make this demo all the
demos and the PowerPoint available on
david's github by the end of the day
yeah end of the day thank you very much
for coming along and we are on a panel
this evening a feature of dotnet if you
want to come and see us talk with a
couple of other folks so I can't
remember right now then do that
otherwise thank you everyone and we'll
see you next time Thanks
you